bonsoir claude bronner merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france de votre
côté ce que vous avez commencé à
vacciner comment s'est passée cette
première journée
et bien aujourd'hui dans notre cabinet
les 20 premiers patients ont été
vaccinées par moi-même et un remplaçant
donc ça s'est très bien passé alors
racontez moi dites moi un peu plus
comment vous avez reçu les doses
combien de doses alors nous avait
proposé comme à tout le monde un flacon
par médecin assure le cabinet de 4 nous
en avons commandé 4 et finalement le
pharmacien en a6 à disposition donc nous
n'avons aucun problème en ce moment pour
vacciner les personnes qui veulent bien
on a démarré aujourd'hui va demain il y
en aura sans doute encore 20 et début de
la semaine prochaine
on continuera encore après on pourront
continuer mais il faudra que con et les
patients parce qu'il ya un moment où ça
va se ralentir les patients c'est à dire
parce qu'alors on est effectivement là
vous avez un discours tellement
surprenant atteint les attentions en
plaisante un peu toute la france où les
français vont venir vous voir à
strasbourg se faire vacciner parce que
y'a quand même plus une pénurie de
vaccins que l' inverse vous en tout cas
vous n'avez pas eu de problème justement
à choisir entre guillemets à trier les
patients devoir faire des choix parfois
compliqué comme certains autres médecins
français je crois que les choix ne sont
pas si compliqué ça parce qu'il y a
aussi des réticences de certains
patients qui attendent un peu que ça ait
démarré donc actuellement quand on
propose à certains patients de venir ils
18 mais ce n'est pas non plus la ruée
vers le vaccin mais bien sûr que ça va
changer assez rapidement
c'est intéressant braun r parce que le
scepticisme des français dont on a
beaucoup parlé ici même vous vous le
ressentez quand même
encore clairement sur le terrain même si
les sondages ont tendance à aller dans
l'autre sens on le ressent un petit peu
mais en fait comme nous sommes les
médecins traitants déjà quand nous
proposons quelque chose c'est beaucoup
plus facilement acceptée et on a
vraiment l'impression que quand ce les
médecins habituels qui en parlent et qui
est lui même convaincu de l'intérêt du
vaccin
c'est quelque chose qui est bien écoutez
donc moi je n'ai pas vraiment ressenti
de de scepticisme
mais par contre j'ai entendu plusieurs
fois aujourd'hui bon mois ci c'est vous
qui vous nous le proposer on est
d'accord
vous avez reçu quel type de vaccin est
est ce que l'accueil a été le même sur
toutes les marques de vaccins en ville
actuellement on ne peut faire que
l'astra zeneca donc on a reçu un flacon
d'astrazeneca 10 doses
on peut même aller à à 12 dans cette
pour certains flacons est et c'est le
seul que nous nous pouvons faire en
ville et les autres sont actuellement
centre et c'est aussi celui qu'on ne
peut faire que jusqu'à 60 50 et ça
laisse donc un trou entre les 65 et 75
ans que la plupart des patients regrette
vraiment beaucoup
alors j'ai souvent d'astrazeneca il ya
beaucoup ou pas de confusion mais enfin
de scepticisme autour de ce vaccin parce
qu'il a été rapporté que dans 10 % des
cas il y avait des effets secondaires
notamment chez certains soignants qu'ils
ont rapporté à ce que c'est compliqué
justement pour vous en cabinet de
n'avoir que ce vaccin à partir du moment
où il ya certains patients qui auront
des effets secondaires comment vous vous
organisez sur ce plan alors les effets
secondaires sont effectivement plus
nombreux que pour les vaccins
arn puisque us ont en gros 10 fois plus
important mais mais on est à moins de 1%
des déclarations et donc on prévient les
patients les effets secondaires
c'est une journée de fièvre c'est des
courbatures
et souvent les patients disent ouais bah
ça nous est déjà arrivé dans le passé
c'est quelque chose qu'on va supporter
après je saurai demain ou après demain
s'il y en a qui vraiment vont me dire
ben dis-donc si j'avais su et
effectivement quand on a vacciné des
services de soignants qu on a vacciné un
peu tout le service
il est arrivé que le lendemain il ya un
tiers des personnes qui manquent
parce qu'ils ont dû prendre un jour de
congé donc il faut y penser il faut
surtout prévenir les patients cela dit
c'est pas cher payé pour être
probablement tranquille après oui c'est
ce que j'allais vous demandez docteur
cesson gravité parce qu'on nous dit
voilà circulez ya rien à voir on
entendait alain fischer tout à l'heure
lors de la conférence voilà nous
expliquer qu'il fallait prendre un
doliprane éventuellement en prévention
mais enfin c'est ça s'arrête là les
effets secondaires finalement pas grave
oui on ne parle pas des faits graves on
parle des effets génome vaccin et qui
sont assez nombreux c'est au point que
la nsm la déclaration de la
pharmacovigilance a fait passer un
message pour dire arrêtez de nous
déclarer les fièvres et les courbatures
à mon avis c'était un peu noyé mais
c'est vrai que la consigne c'est de ne
pas les déclarer
puisque c'est connu et que ses attendus
alors le premier ministre a évoqué des
autres traitements les premiers
traitements à base d'anticorps
monoclonaux qui seront prochainement
disponibles en france est une thérapie
prometteuse selon vous mais ça a fait
ses preuves puisque on diminue en gros
les hospitalisations d'un facteur 4
donc c'est vraiment intéressant et là
aussi à strasbourg les les tout premiers
patients ont été sélectionnés
aujourd'hui ils ont pas encore eu les
les injections
enfin la perfusion mais mais ça se met
en route et ça se met en route de
manière extrêmement rapide
merci en tout cas dr bronner médecin
généraliste à strasbourg vice président
du syndicat de l'union des généralistes
d'avoir été avec nous pour évoquer donc
cette première journée vaccination dans
les cabinets des généralistes merci à
vous